how are you doing I'm good ma'am okay um
so this is the last Medea movie I have
to ask well what was it like having that
conversation with your accountant or
business manager and did they pull you
aside and said we need to talk no no
there is never been and I've always put
a person has made my own decisions of
what are we gonna do how we're gonna do
it and from the beginning I knew that
this character had a purpose for me it
was the purpose for a lot of people but
also for me in business is that a
purpose and I think she served that
purpose and it's been wonderful
what was it about now as the time to
retire the character have you thought
about doing it sooner I had but I wanted
to finish the studio first so just
finished building the studio and I'm
turning 50 this year so I don't want to
be her age playing her so it's about
time to just let it go hang up the dress
I brought up the studio something I
actually wanted to talk to you about
first of all congratulations thank you
that is an amazing amazing achievement
thank you so what is it like owning a
330 Acre studio with your name on it
which has all this amazing production
coming to it it's it's been phenomenal
it's been encouraging it's been just
every drain that I could have imagined
it it's also a huge responsibility but
but I wouldn't trade it for anything and
and I'm grateful for every moment of it
for sure well one of the things I'm
curious about is Atlanta is known as a
great state to shoot because of the 30%
tax rebate are you before behind the
studio are you sort of talking to like
the governor or the government and
saying hey is this tax rebate gonna stay
because it's kind of integral for so
many things coming yeah but also the
great thing about my studio is its
proprietary for me and I got the very
first tax credit ever given in Georgia
so I was there filming before so I've
been on the forefront of fighting for
that tax credit for a long time but if
it I hope it never goes away because it
has changed the the entire state and
billions of dollars are coming into the
state because of it so it'd be foolish
to get rid of it in my opinion to get
rid of it in my opinion but my show is
proprietary now and and all of my shows
are gonna be there my last thing for you
when you're signing that contract to buy
that which must have been the biggest
thing you've ever done in your life how
nervous are you when you're actually
signing on that dotted line the great
thing about my life is that I grew into
it I
you know it's it's it's like signing for
your first house that's $100,000 and
once you once you move to your next
house it's easier in the next house if
it's more expensive it's easier and
easier so I had growth up to it so it
wasn't that big of a responsibility it
wasn't that big of a deal at that moment
I was just again thankful uh you got to
work with David Fincher a number of
years ago and I'm curious because he's
brilliant what did you take away
anything from that experience as a
director that you sort of applied to the
few the things you've worked on since
then
not Medea are you kidding me no there's
not a damn thing my dear is if they did
from what I learned on Fincher but I did
in acrimony I did Justin talking to him
and Ben Affleck them those guys are
brilliant man and listening to them
talking and their passion for lenses and
lighting and nuance and things that I
them me and them ever thought about that
I'd started so I put some of that in
acrimony thinking about my experience
with them actually wrote that movie
after doing gone girl so so yeah he was
very very inspiration for me I loved
working with him yeah he does 50 billion
takes but I love working with it yeah
III think he's it yeah my last thing
you're on the doing a tour right now
whose idea was it to do three shows in
one day you know the thing about it is
this show is very very expensive and I
should have just did an arena tour but I
don't like playing arenas I want to go
back to the theaters I started in and
they're much smaller so to make it work
financially and micro sometimes we've
got to do three shows and and you know
the cast is all for it I'm all for it so
we're working working
[Music]